it is exceptionally busy on the waters
around dover
matt coca knows the channel well he also
knows its dangers
he was at sea when the frantic may day
call came in
as soon as i heard it i i knew it was
going to be very serious whenever you
hear the call mayday people in the water
you know that it's it you know it's a
it's an all-out sort of sprint for
people to get there
to rescue them
border force is stepping up patrols with
jet skiers out early
and a spotter plane overhead
so to give you a sense of the extra
patrols border force are putting on
there's a small rib else on the water at
the moment it's scanning and searching
close to the shoreline looking for those
smaller boats
but with the winds worsening it's
unlikely more are coming
these are some of the last to arrive
picked up overnight and lucky to have
made land
the desperate victims of conscienceless
criminals
we found networks of smugglers selling
routes into europe
even claiming their journeys are safe
matt coca says the gangs are noticeably
more organized
you know when it first started it was
very it seemed just to disorganize
scramble across the channel really i
mean people used to grab anything that
floated and and they would have a go to
get across but now it seems a well-oiled
machine
they're using these large
dinghies which are purposely made for
for one time use just to transport
people across the channel
we showed matt the dinghy that sunk
i think the dinghy has been overloaded
and it's broke up underneath them so it
was the sheer weight the [ __ ]
yeah and also the poor quality of the
way the dinghy has been made
this is the reason why so many people
try to cross the channel on wednesday
then the sea was like a piece of glass
now the weather has really changed and
there is no way you would want to
attempt this journey on these waves in a
dinghy
the channel will be rough for days
but once the weather calms everyone
knows the crossings will continue
laura bundock sky news dover